California governor Gavin Newsom trying
to spread the gospel of his failed
Progressive policies to a red State near
you the liberal leaders showing up in
republican-led states to bash GOP
Governors as evil fascists
the problem in our country right now
authoritarian leaders who are so
hell-bent on gaining power and keeping
it by whatever means necessary no we
have a big battle coming which is why
we'll help lead the fight to make sure
we elect leaders in 2024 who believe in
democracy what's happening in those red
States
not who we are it's Un-American it's
undemocratic
you know Greg the Un-American the
undemocratic part it's really amazing to
me it you know here's a guy who decides
that uh I guess California is all good
so he's going to spread the word to Red
States yeah it's like it's like somehow
it's more American to let people die on
your streets it's more American not to
to not to arrest people Gavin Newsom is
basically flinging mud while he's neck
deep in his sewer he talks about
authoritarianism in red States but who
is more free there's nothing less free
than a lawless State the only thing
worse than a police state is no police
at all state it's a criminal State he
governs a criminal State you know it's
one and if you look at the most
dangerous places on Earth they had South
Sudan Dr Congo they're no laws there's
free as hell but they are hell that's
what you're when you see certain parts
of California where his friends don't
live or where he doesn't live or the
Pelosi's don't live they look like a
fourth world country if those indeed
exist I don't know California is a
fourth world country yep okay Harold
Newsome's move sounds a lot like I'm
running in 2024.
um I think he has said that he's going
to stand down Joe Biden but maybe I
agree with you this is certainly a
rhetoric where you're like almost as if
you're trying to Define define the
choice in an election I'm not surprised
by by some of this nor am I surprised by
the reaction of some campaigns are
always about the future and and Governor
Newsom believes that California
represents the future of America better
than I think he put up two Governors I
saw where Governor Abbott and Governor
DeSantis Governor DeSantis talks a lot
about why Florida is great and he has
every right so he's a governor and I
assume he thinks his policies are the
reason why what what I what I think is
would be more more powerful for any
Governor be it DeSantis Abbott in this
case Mr Newsom is to do the things you
just said they're real challenges he's
facing in his State I think you're
elected president there was a time I'm
52 I feel like I'm 92 sometimes when I
talk about when there was a time but
there was a time when you ran on your
record of what you've done in your state
and why you believed you could do even
better things for the country Governor
Newsom has some things to campaign on
but there's some glaring things that
we've talked about in the Press
homelessness to crime and other things
if he were able to tackle those I think
in a way that uh created a positive
National narrative I think his his
chances would boost would be boosted
tremendously whether he runs this time
or doesn't run it off for that matter he
never used to be like this right
no remember he wasn't this crazy I mean
he's always been a little crazy I think
it's recent that he's gone woke and when
he was mayor of SF he wasn't this nutty
anyway oh he's better he's been a
conservative Democrat he was on the wing
of the Clinton wing of the party yeah
but that's good he's that part of him is
dead you know it's amazing that he
criticizes Florida he criticizes Ron
DeSantis I mean it's pretty clear
DeSantis is someone who's going to be
running for president but how can he
make an honest argument when they're
trying to sexualize kids in Florida you
know allowing them to read books it
describes how you have sex
Etc
he's not making an honest argument he's
a politician so he's like the second
string quarterback who has to stay loose
in case something happens to the
starting quarterback and Biden's not
announcing he's running it looks like
it's on the fall or yeah late summer so
Gavin is just waiting in the wings in
case anything shakes out with Joe and he
ran it by Biden he told the White House
he was going to campaign in these red
States if he was campaigning in swing
states that would be more threatening
but he's going to deep red States still
connecting with donors still testing out
lines getting his legs loose but he's
not really threatening the White House
if he was doing big foreign policy
speeches in South Carolina big economic
speeches in New Hampshire the Biden
White House would say cut that out but
they're allowing him to do this out of
respect and just out of this slight
chance that Joe doesn't run
he is distinguishing himself though as a
cultural Warrior on the left the way Ron
DeSantis is views that way on the right
this is his now his brand I don't know
if people really love that outside of
California that doesn't go over well
well you know California Martha is one
of the states where people are moving
from not moving to that's exactly what I
was going to say you know you one I
think I think people don't always
understand when they make these kind of
arguments is states rights right so the
people in this states that he's talking
about are a choosing to move there in
the case of Florida or Texas and B they
are voting on referendums they're voting
on all of the laws that take place in
their state and they're choosing that
state because they like the way it works
right so they're not necessarily
choosing California and businesses are
not choosing California the taxes are
Sky High the regulations are Sky High
it's onerous to run a business in
California so I mean you know you can
say that these people are authoritarian
but the fact is that people are choosing
to move to those States and live there
for the reasons of how they're run hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now